Cada vez que nos hablan de México, es muy
probable que pensemos en tacos, tequila y
mariachis, ¡Ay esas rancheras!
Pero, por desgracia, también es muy probable
que un instante después pensemos también
violencia, narcotráfico y crimen organizado.
De hecho, este mismo año 2023 ha empezado
con una noticia que ha dado la vuelta al mundo,
fijaos:
N1(6 de enero de 2023:El cártel de Sinaloa
lanza una violenta respuesta cuando México
recaptura al hijo de El Chapo.
The Guardian.
Lógicamente, que detengan a un narco es una
buena noticia, pero, sin embargo, sus consecuencias
inmediatas pueden no serlo tanto.
Cuando cae un pez gordo, de repente se desatan
enormes olas de violencia a la que tristemente
muchos mexicanos ya se han acostumbrado.
La realidad, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
es que la violencia está tan arraigada en
la sociedad mexicana que, incluso, ya forma
parte de la cultura popular.
Estoy seguro que prácticamente todos habéis
oído hablar de los corridos mexicanos, canciones
y baladas sobre política, romances e historia.
Y seguro, seguro que también habéis oído
hablar de su variante más controvertida:
los“narcocorridos”, canciones que cuentan
las historias de los narcos, a quienes presentan,
incluso de manera heroica.
Y, siendo honestos, aunque México es mucho
más que todo eso, desgraciadamente tiene
bastante sentido que a esociemos este país
con el mundo del narcotráfico.
Al fin y al cabo es su puerta natural de entrada
al gigantesco y codiciado mercado de Estados
Unidos.
A los narcos les viene que ni pintando estar
tan cerca del mayor centro de consumo mundial
de narcóticos.
Pero, un momento, esto por sí solo no nos
explica por qué hay tanta violencia en México.
Al final y al cabo si todo fuese por la frontera,
los narcos podrían haberse establecido también
en Canadá, ¿no os parece?.
Pues bien, echad un vistazo a este mapa:
Lo que estáis viendo en pantalla es un mapa
que divide la ciudad de El Paso, en Texas,
y Ciudad Juárez, en México.
Este punto ha sido siempre considerado como
uno de los más calientes del narcotráfico
americano.
Pero, ¿y si os dijera que El Paso está considerada
como una de las grandes ciudades más seguras
de Estados Unidos mientras que en cambio Ciudad
Juárez una de las más violentas de todo
México?
De hecho, Ciudad Juárez fue considerada en
2021 como la segunda ciudad mexicana con mayor
número de homicidios por cada 100.000 habitantes.
Entonces, el problema no puede ser solamente
el narcotráfico.
¿No os parece?
Pues por ahí van los tiros, nunca mejor dicho.
Para muchos el auténtico problema de este
país no son en sí mismo los narcos sino
sobre todo la debilidad y la corrupción de
muchas de las instituciones mexicanas.
Incluso hay expertos que apuntan que gran
parte de México sería algo así como un
estado fallido dónde muchos ciudadanos confían
más en los narcos que en el propio estado.
O quizás el problema sea que en esas zonas
el estado no pinta prácticamente nada y todo
el control está en manos de esos mismos narcos.
¡Cómo para hacerles frente!
Tal vez por eso desde que en el año 2000
el gobierno mexicano empezó a enfrentarse
al narcotráfico de manera directa, la violencia
se ha disparado y hoy es ya con mucha diferencia
el mayor problema del país.
El mayor problema y, también una de las grandes
prioridades del actual presidente, Andrés
Manuel López Obrador.
La pregunta, por tanto, que podemos hacernos
es: ¿Por qué sigue habiendo tanta violencia
en México?
¿Hasta qué punto tienen poder los cárteles
mexicanos?
¿Qué éxitos está cosechando realmente
AMLO?
Hoy en este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
T1(ENEMIGOS ÍNTIMOS)
En general, la relación entre narcotraficantes
y gobiernos ha sido bastante turbia y tormentosa.
Nunca sabes lo que te vas a encontrar.
Por ejemplo, desde que Estados Unidos declaró
la guerra contra las drogas en 1971 bajo la
presidencia de Richard Nixon, decenas y decenas
de gobiernos de todo el mundo han multiplicado
sus esfuerzos para intentar acabar con los
narcos.
Sin embargo, la cruda realidad es que todos
estos esfuerzos no han servido para gran cosa:
los narcos siguen colocando su mercancía
a diestro y siniestro a lo largo de toda Europa
y Estados Unidos…
Lo que explica, por ejemplo, que los precios
en la calle se hayan mantenido razonablemente
estables durante los últimos años.
Hablamos de toda una gigantesca industria
milmillonaria cuyas redes de poder llegan
a salpicar a quienes se supone que tienen
que enfrentarse a ellos.
La situación es tal que incluso se cree que
la CIA, el FBI o la propia DEA han llegado
a “permitir” la entrada de narcóticos
en Estados Unidos para poder atrapar a los
peces gordos.
Ahora bien, si hay un país dónde con el
paso del tiempo se ha hecho más conocida
la colaboración entre estado, políticos
y narcos ese es, precisamente, México.
Sin ir más lejos, uno de los partidos con
más escándalos y acusaciones por sus nexos
con el narco no es otro que el Partido Revolucionario
Institucional, más conocido como el PRI.
Claro, hablamos de un partido que ha controlado
el gobierno de México durante más de 60
años.
Y eso, queridos amigos, eso es mucho tiempo.
Tanto como para poder hacer amigos en el mismísimo
infierno.
Y de hecho, si por algo se ha caracterizado
la historia del PRI es por estar plagada de
todo tipo de acusaciones de fraude electoral
y, sobre todo, de corrupción.
Pero no de cualquier corrupción, sino de
la corrupción vinculada al narcotráfico
y al crimen organizado.
¿Queréis un ejemplo?
Pues ahí tenemos casos como el de Raúl Salinas
de Gortari, uno de los hermanos del expresidente
Salinas de Gortari, que se vio seriamente
involucrado en corruptelas con el Cártel
del Golfo en los años 80.
Fue arrestado en 1995.
Ahora bien, durante las seis décadas de gobiernos
del PRI, la narcoviolencia no llegó nunca
a ser un problema tan grave como lo es hoy.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿qué demonios ha
cambiado?
Pues veréis.
Durante el tiempo en el que el PRI estuvo
en el poder se estableció una especie de
pacto no escrito por el que los narcos gozaban
de cierta libertad de actuación siempre y
cuando no sembraran el caos en el país.
Es decir, si se portaban más o menos bien,
podían hacer lo que les diera la real gana.
Y de hecho, el PRI vio una oportunidad de
oro para perpetuarse en el poder, gracias
a su mano ancha con los narcotraficantes y
el crimen organizado, estos le garantizaban
cierta paz social.
Sin embargo, su vecino del norte, Estados
Unidos no estaba precisamente satisfecho con
este papel.
Para los gringos la lucha contra las drogas
era una cuestión crucial, y lo era incluso
desde antes de que Nixon declarase oficialmente
la “guerra contra el narco”.
Por ejemplo, ya en 1948 tuvo lugar la primera
campaña de exterminio de cultivos de opiáceos
en México.
Y ahí no termina todo.
Desde 1948, al PRI le tocó hacer malabares
entre los intereses de Estados Unidos y los
del PRI.
Y eso que, frecuentemente, apuntaban a direcciones
contrarias.
Por eso, a pesar de que los gobiernos del
PRI llevaron a cabo operaciones tan conocidas
como la Cóndor de los 70, para perseguir
a narcos y desmantelar cultivos en los Altos
del Sinaloa, en realidad no se les hizo mucho
daño.
Digamos que estas operaciones funcionaron,
más bien, como una forma de calmar a Estados
Unidos y convencerles de que México, por
fin, se había puesto las pilas.
Y mientras tanto, los propios jerifaltes políticos
mexicanos disfrutaban de todo su poder.
Eso sí, siempre y cuándo no molestaran a
las mafias y cárteles locales.
Ambos ganaban y nadie se quejaba.
Más o menos las cosas funcionaban.
¿El problema?
Pues que tarde o temprano los narcos se volvieron
tan asquerosamente ricos que empezaron a tener
cada vez más influencia sobre gran parte
de la ciudadanía mexicana.
Y, claro, es justo, en ese momento, cuando
te das cuenta de que los narcos pueden convertirse
en toda una co mpetencia para el poder político
y militar del propio Estado, cuando decides
ponerte a luchar de una vez por todas contra
ellos.
¿El problema?
Pues que quizás en México ese momento llegó
demasiado tarde.
Atentos.
T2(LA GUERRA TOTAL)
Nuevo siglo, nuevo gobierno, debieron de pensar
los mexicanos.
Nada más empezar el año 2000, un nuevo presidente
tomó el poder: Vicente Fox.
¿Del PRI?
¡No!
Por primera vez después de seis décadas,
el PRI perdió el poder.
El PAN, el Partido de Acción Nacional se
hizo con las riendas tras celebrarse el primer
traspaso pacífico de gobierno en México
desde la Revolución de principios del siglo
XX.
Comenzaba, entonces, una nueva época y, con
ella, una nueva política frente a los narcos.
El nuevo presidente Vicente Fox se alineó
con los intereses de Estados Unidos y puso
en marcha una enorme ofensiva contra el crimen
organizado.
Y no precisamente como las del PRI que buscaban
más aparentar que ser realmente efectivas.
No, esta vez, amigos, era de verdad.
El Ejército comenzó a tener un papel más
destacado en la lucha contra las drogas.
Y de hecho, el gobierno de Fox aprobó una
nueva Ley de Seguridad Nacional que le daba
más capacidad al Ejército para actuar en
asuntos civiles en tiempo de paz.
Y desde entonces fue directo a por los capos
de los cárteles.
Por eso, durante su presidencia no fue extraño
ver noticias como esta:
N2(México golpea al narcotráfico con la
captura del jefe del cártel de Tijuana.
El País)
Maravilloso, ¿no creéis?
Pues, la realidad es que su estrategia de
usar al Ejército y escalar la lucha contra
los narcos dio frutos dulces, sí, pero también
otros muy amargos.
El tráfico de drogas a Estados Unidos no
se frenó sino que, incluso, siguió creciendo,
los cárteles se fragmentaron y de repente
las tasas de violencia se elevaron como un
cohete.
Al final, durante la presidencia de Fox el
número de nuevos cárteles y grupos criminales
organizados creció como la espum a.
Digamos que caía un capo y surgían 2.
Y, ojo, porque si pensáis que la situación
no podía ser peor, estáis muy equivocados.
Después de Fox llegó Felipe Calderón y
la lucha se intensificó.
De hecho, Calderón es el presidente que proclamó
formalmente en México la guerra contra las
drogas.
Lo hizo mano a mano con Estados Unidos gracias
a la Iniciativa Mérida.
Y, ¿en qué consistía su estrategia?
Pues básicamente en luchar frontalmente contra
los narcos.
Y cuando digo frontalmente digo a luchar con
todos los recursos posibles como se si se
tratara de una guerra de verdad.
La violencia se disparó aún más y lo que
es aún peor, el estado no pudo ganar la guerra.
En 2012 de repente parecía que todo se iba
a parar de golpe y plumazo.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque ese año volvió el PRI al poder
de la mano de Enrique Peña Nieto.
Y la verdad es que las cosas cambiaron, pero
a peor.
Fijaos en esta gráfica:
El nuevo gobierno del PRI registró las cifras
más sangrientas de la historia mexicana.
Con Vicente Fox, el número de homicidios
anuales se mantuvo estable, con Calderón
empezaron a subir como la espuma pero con
Peña Nieto…
bueno, digamos que batieron todos los récords
en 2018.
No parecía que hubiera nada que hacer.
Y entonces en 2018, apareció una figura que
prometió cambiar por completo la estrategia
de seguridad.
Atentos.
T3(ABRAZOS, NO BALAZOS)
A estas alturas de la película, que un líder
populista se convierta en el presidente de
un país latinoamericano no es noticia.
Esta es la tierra perfecta para las cosechas
de populistas: Hugo Chávez, Cristina Kirchner,
Rafael Correa, Evo Morales, Gustavo Petro,
Nayib Bukele…
Estoy seguro de que son nombres que no nos
pillan por sorpresa.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
México no es la excepción.
En 2018 llegó a la presidencia mexicana nuestro
ya conocido Andrés Manuel López Obrador,
AMLO.
Hijo de comerciantes y descendiente de españoles
e indígenas, AMLO comenzó su andadura en
la política paradójicamente con el PRI.
Sin embargo, después de las fraudulentas
elecciones de 1988, se pasó al Partido de
la Revolución Democrática, con el que llegó
a ser Jefe de Gobierno del Distrito Federal
entre los años 2000 y 2005.
A partir de entonces, poco a poco su popularidad
fue creciendo hasta que finalmente en 2018
al tercer intentó ganó las elecciones presidenciales.
Y, ojo, porque AMLO tradicionalmente no sólo
ha destacado por sus mensajes, su estilo populista
o, incluso, sus excentricidades, sino también
por el discurso que lleva décadas defendiendo
contra la estrategia militarista que han empleado
los diferentes gobiernos mexicanos en su lucha
contra el narco.
De hecho, el nombre de su estrategia es tremendamente
pegadizo.
Fijaos.
Abrazos, no balazos.
Suena super bonito, ¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, la realidad, queridos amigos,
es
que el éxito del eslogan no se ha trasladado
en la práctica ni mucho menos.
Fijaos:
N3(Los homicidios descienden, pero el sexenio
de AMLO se perfila como el más violento -Expansión)
Desde que AMLO se hizo con el poder, no ha
logrado reducir demasiado las tasas de criminalidad.
De hecho, en los dos primeros años de su
presidencia, 2019 y 2020, se reportaron casi
el mismo número de homicidios que en el fatídico
último año de Peña Nieto.
Y de hecho, al final, su promesa de desmilitarizar
la seguridad ciudadana y devolver al Ejército
a los cuarteles, cayó en saco roto.
Y es que de hecho AMLO ha cambiado tanto de
opinión, que su proyecto estrella, la Guardia
Nacional, ha dejado de ser una institución
con mando civil para ser dirigida por el Sedena,
la Secretaría de la Defensa Nacional.
Dicho de otra forma, ha militarizado la Guardia
Nacional que él mismo creó en 2019, precisamente,
para sacar al ejército de las calles.
Y no solo eso, ahora incluso está delegado
tareas civiles en el Ejército.
A ver, es verdad que esto del arte del donde
dije digo, digo Diego no es nada nuevo en
México, pero sí que llama la atención viniendo
de AMLO, un líder que puso tanto énfasis
durante toda su carrera política en la desmilitarización
de la seguridad pública.
Ahora, sin embargo, es todo lo contrario.
Incluso está poniendo a las Fuerzas Armadas
por las nubes.
C1(“(SEMAR es la dependencia) más preparada
para defender la soberanía y enfrentar las
amenazas del contrabando y la introducción
de droga” – AMLO, 2021)
El problema es que con tanto elogio el presidente
olvida la corrupción.
Sin ir más lejos, en octubre del 2022 salieron
a la luz los llamados Guacamaya Leaks, que
expusieron decenas de miles de emails, conversaciones
y expedientes oficiales del Sedena.
decenas de miles de emails, conversaciones
Expedientes y conversaciones sobre todo tipo
de asuntos: desde la propia salud de AMLO
hasta los negocios del Ejército, que ahora
se encarga también de la construcción de
infraestructuras.
Por eso, no es extraño que nos encontremos
con noticias como esta:
N4(Militares son acusados de irregularidades
financieras en la construcción de sucursales
del Banco del Bienestar.
InfoBae)
En cierto modo es lo que suele pasar cuando
mezclas armas, poder y corrupción.
La duda ahora es, ¿le está mereciendo la
pena a AMLO hacer exactamente todo lo contrario
a lo que prometió en materia de seguridad?
O, dicho de otra manera, ¿le está funcionando
la nueva estrategia a AMLO?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T4(LOS NARCOTANQUES)
Los tanques y los blindados ahora se han puesto
de moda, aunque sólo sea porque se espera
que Ucrania reciba decenas y decenas de tanques
durante este año.
Pero incluso antes de que los blindados militares
se pusieran de moda, los narcos ya le habían
echado un ojo a esta posibilidad: utilizar
blindados para consolidar su poder territorial
en México.
A ver, es cierto que no son blindados fabricados
por la sofisticada industria militar, sino
algo bastante más de andar por casa… pero
siguen siendo peligrosos.
Estoy hablando de los llamados narcotanques,
bichos como este:
(FOTO: https://www.bbc.com/mundo/noticias-america-latina-60486794)
Y, claro, ahora, os estaréis preguntando:
pero a ver, si hasta los narcos tienen ya
sus propios tanques caseros, ¿realmente es
posible que AMLO pueda mejorar la seguridad
del país?
Pues, en principio, las cifras dicen que sí,
no mucho…
Pero algo es algo.
(Desde la llegada de López Obrador, el crimen
ha seguido muy activo tal y como ocurrió
con sus predecesores.
Sin embargo, también es cierto que en 2021
consiguió que los homicidios disminuyeran
un 4,3% con respecto al año anterior.
Y lo que es aún mejor, en 2021 se produjeron
de media unos 26.6 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes, es decir, 9 homicidios más por
cada 100.000 habitantes que en 2015.
Por otro lado, los casos de delitos graves
y de secuestro han seguido manteniendo la
tendencia a la baja que iniciaron en 2019.
A ver, no nos malinterpretéis,la verdad es
que los datos siguen siendo desoladores, y
la estrategia de militarización sigue siendo
un pozo sin fondo que no consigue los resultados
esperados
Quizás derrotar a los narcos va a necesitar
de otros métodos.
Y es aquí donde tenemos que tener en cuenta
que el propio funcionamiento de los cárteles
hace que sea muy difícil acabar con ellos.
No olvidéis que utilizan métodos de combate
y armas cada vez más avanzadas: drones, narcotanques,
incluso armamento usado por la propia infantería
estadounidense, como las ametralladoras Browning
M2 de calibre .50.
Y, claro, si a esto le unimos que las instituciones
mexicanas no llegan a todo el país es lógico
que los cárteles no desaparezcan.
Es más, ¿recordáis cuando al principio
de este vídeo os contamos la detención de
Ovidio Guzmán, el hijo del Chapo Guzmán?
Bueno, pues Ovidio es el capo del Cártel
de Sinaloa desde que México extraditó a
su padre a ñps Estados Unidos en 2017.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Creéis que aunque hayan
detenido a Ovidio Guzmán, el Cártel de Sinaloa
va a dejar de traficar con drogas, extorsionar
a quien le interese, o traficar con personas?
Exacto: ¡Lo habéis adivinado, por supuesto
que no!
Y es que este es uno de los puntos clave del
narcotráfico y del crimen organizado en México:
ya no son organizaciones piramidales, ahora
tienen una organización descentralizada con
puntos que trabajan de manera independiente.
Es decir, que, si cae el líder, ya no cae
el equipo al completo, sino que en la práctica
todo sigue más o menos como si no hubiera
pasado absolutamente nada.
Así que todo apunta a que la estrategia de
AMLO va a resultar otro fracaso más en la
ya larga lucha contra el narco mexicano.
Y ojo, hablamos de fracaso no porque no haya
conseguido alguna mejora, ya hemos visto que
eso no es así.
En cualquier caso,los cárteles están muy
bien blindados, y el Estado mexicano no cuenta
con una estrategia capaz de hacerles frente
para diezmarlos de una vez por todas.
La idea de AMLO de “abrazos, no balazos”,
no está cosechando sus frutos y México sigue
siendo uno de los países más peligrosos
del mundo en el que los narcos no dan abrazos,
sino bombazos y secuestros.
Esta es la terrible realidad que se vive en
México pero ahora la pregunta es para ti,
¿crees que AMLO logrará darle la vuelta
a la tortilla antes de abandonar la presidencia?
¿Qué alternativa a la militarización crees
que podemos encontrar?
¿Sale de verdad a cuenta la guerra contra
las drogas?Podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta
aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.